the heading is a little long and awkward
I admit it's literally the very last
moment before we actually get to know
how to differentiate and integrate tree
Demetri functions but we've had a lot of
groundwork to lay and this is somewhat I
guess you could regard as the last piece
okay
it's the head of years behavior of sine
X and tan X for small X it's not the
same as their heading that's in the
textbook but I like mine better which is
why I put a bit now what I'm going to do
right now is I'm going to I'm going to
show you a strange proof but I want to
give you first the intuition for why we
would even embark on this proof to begin
with I remember this great teacher I had
years and years ago and he said always
guess when you're uncertain about
something always guess and use your
intuition because one of two things will
happen you'll be wrong with your guess
in which case no big deal it was just
yes or you'll be right and you'll feel
like a freaking genius right so what I
want to point out to you I want to
remind the people who are in my class
last year and for those who weren't this
might be completely brand-new to you I
want to talk about sine and tan and what
they actually are in a very similar way
to how I talked about what a Radian was
and I somewhat redefined it for you okay
so this is our friend can you tell me
what this is you can tell me what this
is right there's enough information
clues on here to tell you this is the
unit circle right I mean you can see
it's a circle you've got radius one and
if it wasn't obvious enough equation is
hiding over here not doing a very good
job of hiding okay so you got the unit
circle and the reason why the unit
circle should be a sensible place for
your brain to go when you think about
these objects is because trig signing
constant am started with right-angled
triangles right it started with oh
you've got an angle you've got a right
angle triangle you've got some sides and
then what did we define sine cos and tan
as in terms of a triangle like this yeah
very good we say hey let's call this the
opposite side from that angle this is
the adjacent side and this one's always
the hypotenuse and then we just sort of
compare different pairs opposite
hypotenuse opposite adjacent you get the
idea okay but then we realize that
some point around late u10 we realized
that this definition is nice to start
with but it won't cut it because the
only kinds of angles you will ever find
in right angle triangles are acute
angles right the big you can't get
enough juice egg in there if you've got
a 90 a pylon - I should say you'll only
ever get acute angles and there's lots
more angles in the world than acute
angles so that's why we introduced this
guy right importantly we redefined cos
and sine as two things that are on the
board right now how did we redefine them
we forgot the triangles some what we
said caused insane work can anyone tell
me why am I saying it that order causing
science rather than cause yeah very good
see these coordinates here right these
are the coordinates they correspond to
the angle subtended at the center of the
circle with the positive x-axis right
and we said those coordinates are
causing the same yeah which is why we
got to much more useful things like say
90 degrees right you can't fit that in
to try a right angle triangle either but
because we'll be cause of degrees will
be the x coordinate which would be in
this case what's the x coordinate the X
could one it up here is zero so cos of
90 is zero sine of 90 would be the y
coordinate which would be now you can
say it one right so and then we can go
over here we can have negatives all that
kind of thing which was clearly you know
you can't have negatives when you think
about ratios of Lights but we went much
better okay
so what I remind you of is that if sine
is this vertical coordinate then I can
put sign on like this okay so if I
animate this that blue line however long
that is the length of that blue line is
sine of that angle is that okay you're
okay with that idea you can see so I get
longer and shorter as the angle varies
and I'm just interested in acute angles
for now because I'm trying to think
about small values of x okay now let me
just hit pause on that now I wanted R
and we did a long time ago so I might be
surprised if you say no but I'm gonna
put the people in my class on the spot
and say stop
how do I I want to put the keyboard away
go away oh I feel bad for mrs. Lee's
hope she's okay there we go okay so I'm
gonna put my clasp on the spot and I'm
gonna say who remembers we've redefined
signing cause as y-coordinate
x-coordinate
how did we redefine tan in terms of this
get away from this right angle triangle
get away from opposite and adjacent
where on earth this tan on this because
the answer that question is why Tan is
called tan tans an abbreviation right
it's an abbreviation for tangent and in
this context you're like huh
what does tangent have to do with
anything like this right we'll let me
remind you is lots of ways to show you
this but this is I think that my
favorite and the clearest one see that
tangent there that tangent it goes from
the point that's been submitted on the
circumference down to the x-axis right
just like this angle is from that line
to the x-axis positive x-axis that line
of the tangent I should say that
interval the length of that interval is
10 let me say that again for people who
were in my class last year this we
completely brand-new probably because
very few people draw attention to it
that tangent its length is 10 of theá--
okay now think about that way the way
that works for instance figure out what
happens as theta or in my case a sorry
my finger as bad a think about what
happens as that angle gets really close
to 90 degrees what's happening to tan
it's increasing and it's increasing
increasing forever right at a certain
point namely sorry my aim sucks
maybe that point right there when you
try and feed in 90 degrees what happens
to the tangent well it's a straight line
that goes right across here and
consequently never returns to the what
there it is never touch the axis right
so therefore what is that length it
doesn't have a wake which is why if you
think about what turn looks like at 90
degrees I should say peyote
at PI on to pair doesn't have a value
because the tangent the tangent never
returns to the axis does that make sense
okay so
the right here in that's right okay now
I'm ready now I've established what it's
about what does this mean for sine and
tan for small X there are plenty of ways
to reason this but I want to show it to
you one here which look really closely
at what's happening to these blue and
orange lines I'm gonna zoom in for you
just so that it's really ultra obvious
okay what happens as the angle X gets
small
okay well watch I'll do it slowly as it
comes down
look look at what's happening I'm gonna
zoom in even further whoops I went the
wrong way
oh there we go sorry fix that square
there we go are you going even close all
right look at what's happening to the
blue and orange lines I'm gonna make the
angle even tinier okay go away you know
okay now there are two things I want to
observe number one morning mister anyway
two things I wanna observe
number one angles getting small yeah
angles getting really really really tiny
okay what is happening to a sign in town
the lines are they are converging right
they're converging together in fact at a
certain point like it i zoomed in really
far if i if i come all the way back out
you practically can't tell the
difference in sign it's Han at this
point can you write because that tangent
is approaching a vertical line which is
what sine is it's that vertical line
okay so number one they are converging
number two tell me what's happening to
the size of sine and tan they are
getting small and that should be no
surprise like that's kind of an obvious
thing because look as you get closer and
closer to zero tan is also getting
closer to zero and so for that matter
that was badly drawn sorry there we go
so is sine they're both getting small
okay so my intuition remember I told you
always try a guess right always try
guess my intuition is that sine and tan
and I'm gonna go one step further
they'll lie on y equals x right when
they are small they are practically
doing the same
okay let me said that again in its the
playtest language I can we're gonna make
it technical in a second sign and 10 and
X when X gets small they are practically
doing the same thing that's what this
intuition tells me now using this weird
diagram here we're gonna prove it